hablar de viajes es muy agradecido
porque si yo pregunto ahora a quien no
le gusta viajar probablemente nadie
levantaría la mano
realmente salir de casa y encontrarte
amanecer es como este el nanga parbat en
pakistán es realmente un privilegio
la cuestión es que nosotros cada uno de
nosotros nos hemos creado un mundo un
mundo un pequeñito en el que nos
encontramos muy cómodos conocemos los
códigos nos sentimos protegidos sabemos
dónde está la gente las personas que
queremos dónde ir a comprar el pan dónde
comer y ese mundo pequeñito es el
universo que nos hemos creado
inconscientemente desde que somos
pequeños nos los solemos llevar nosotros
cuando viajamos nos los llevamos con
nosotros y es muy difícil romper ese
hilo conductor o ese hilo o cordón
umbilical que te mantiene atado a ese
pequeño universo en el que se desarrolla
tu vida cuando yo me fui con 18 años
pues me fui solo era todavía más tonto
que ahora y muchas veces tuve miedo
claro que sí me sentí soledad
pero también me di cuenta de que había
roto ese cordón umbilical con el pequeño
mundo en el que hasta entonces había
vivido y comencé a disfrutar el viaje
tal y como yo lo entiendo el viaje para
que nos engrandezca como personas para
que nos ayude a desarrollarnos tiene que
ser profundo yo sé que casi todos
viajamos con nuestras cámaras nuestros
por supuesto teléfonos móviles
pendientes de las redes sociales
pendientes de que la gente que se ha
quedado en nuestro pequeño mundo sepa
dónde estamos
y a dónde vamos y todo eso está
fenomenal pero es el día que no tienes
wifi es esa mañana en el que el sudor
frío te recorre porque no hay wifi y a
mí hay gente que me viene y me dice
jorge no hay wifi
y yo le digo bueno es que aquí en este
desierto no han puesto antenas
y tras unos segundos que a veces son
minutos de auténtica desesperación de
auténtico drama
la gente se relaja y empieza a ver el
mundo de otra manera
claro que viajar también conlleva
soledad os lo estaba diciendo esta es mi
tienda de campaña en pleno desierto del
sahara
verdaderamente ahí no hay ni botellón ni
oyes muchos ruidos pero si empiezas a
buscarte ya encontrarte a ti mismo y te
das cuenta antes o después de que te has
ido de casa con una lista de prejuicios
casi inacabable con miedos y con un
interés entre mínimo y cero para con ese
otro
que es el que te vas a encontrar cuando
sales por ahí
claro que viajar te permite ir a sitios
como este marchaba
llegar ahí por la mañana en pleno
desierto de judea es un privilegio y es
fascinante pero para llegar ahí has
tenido que andar cuatro horas sin wifi
aunque hagas las fotos no les vas a
poder colgar de inmediato
la primera vez que a mí me dijeron y el
problema es que a mí siempre que me
dicen oye te atreves a digo que sí sin
pensarlo mi madre todavía me regaña
la primera vez que me dijeron que me
fuera a sudán a abrir una ruta entrando
desde egipto pues cuando yo iba en ese
ferry porque entonces la frontera
terrestre estaba cerrada iba muerto de
miedo y no fue hace tantos años y yo
decía pero porque qué necesidad tenía yo
de estar aquí hoy si es que
verdaderamente cuando yo llegué al
primer puerto de sudán que es muy
tranquilizador porque no ves nada más
que el desierto del sahara
me estaba esperando quien hoy es mi
hermano sudanés ali porque yo quería
contaros sobre todo las personas que
descubres las personas que conoces
cuando viajas con las defensas bajadas
cuando viajas con la mente abierta
cuando viajas consciente de que ese otro
que te está esperando en un puerto de
sudán
con mi amigo nidal en palestina o mi
amigo sala en pakistán esas personas son
personas de a pie como nosotros con sus
familias sus miedos sus sueños sus hijos
sus trabajos
exactamente igual nosotros no elegimos
donde nacemos ellos tampoco pero claro
os he querido traer tres ejemplos que
son un poco oye me está ayudando oye
cruzat 'palestina andando hombre tampoco
es que sea el sitio más tranquilo del
mundo creo yo
vete a pakistán
pero conoces a personas estas tres
personas que os he mostrado hoy o que os
estoy mostrando se han convertido casi
en hermanos
casi en hermanos porque siempre que voy
a estos países
casi exijo viajar con ellos y son ellos
los que me ayudan a subirme a un camión
como ese esto qué estáis viendo aquí es
un medio de transporte local en sudán
sudán del norte para que lo
diferenciamos y la gente ahí bueno yo no
sé si lo veis no lleva cinturón
no llevan móviles eso que se ve por ahí
son bastones no son armas pero fijaos
bien en una cosa que es lo que me sigue
fascinando y me sigue haciendo querer
seguir viajando hasta probablemente el
final de mis días su sonrisa
yo de verdad he conocido tanta gente que
me ha sonreído que me ha abrazado que me
ha ofrecido su trozo de fruta su té su
casa me ha llevado con su familia en
muchísimos sitios del mundo y me ha
hecho mejor persona me ha enriquecido
como viajero claro que sí porque dejado
mi pequeño mundo en casa
y he sido capaz de vencer mis propios
prejuicios y decir pero vamos a ver
porque me considero yo mejor que todas
estas personas para nada somos
diferentes claro que sí pero en esa
diferencia está también la variedad y lo
divertido
esta familia por ejemplo estuve un día
entero con ellos pescando en el mekong y
lo que pescaban es lo que iba a cenar su
familia esa noche
estaban sonriendo y riéndose yo ya al
principio decía bueno es como mi amigo
khalid en sudán que cuando yo bajé de
ese ferry me dijo estás muy pálido digo
tú no
y luego me di cuenta de que había sido
una canallada
pero todavía se ríe
mi amigo sala en pakistán por ejemplo la
primera vez que fui me decía por qué
estás tan tenso suéltate y hombres' a la
xvii de osama bin laden sabes y esto no
se es un país complicado es un trozo del
paraíso no os voy a decir a todos que os
vayáis la semana que viene que podríais
pero verdaderamente te das cuenta al
viajar de que lo que nosotros vemos por
la televisión en los medios y hoy se ha
hablado aquí de ello muchas veces no es
la realidad es mejor ir y verlo por uno
mismo es mejor acercarse a esas personas
con una sonrisa yo creo que cuando uno
sonríe solo puede recibir más sonrisas y
cuando uno da siempre recibe más
vosotros estáis de acuerdo
yo creo que no gracias a vosotros no si
yo esto lo hago para que os vengáis
conmigo de viaje un día
pero sí que es verdad que
cuando yo me fui de mochilero bueno
aparte de que me querían traer a
collejas a casa
me di cuenta de que hay situaciones que
dan miedo
pues sí en casa también el mundo es un
lugar maravilloso igual que la vida y al
final recorrer el mundo también es
recorrer la vida es cada uno en la
medida de sus posibilidades yo tengo la
grandísima fortuna de que me dedico a
esto profesionalmente y me pagan por
viajar lo cual sé que suena al trabajo
idílico y lo es
no lo es de verdad que sí pero pero
realmente también os enseño a mi tienda
no os voy a enseñar los baños públicos
porque no existen en muchos sitios
y busca un enchufe para cargar algo
tampoco comer comer lo que se dice comer
comida española como aquí en león que es
buenísima entre 0 y nada pero cuando
vuelves a casa y esto yo de verdad os
digo que es así cuando tú sales relajado
y dices mira
vamos a descubrir que hay ahí al otro
lado vamos a descubrir a ese otro que
tiene el mismo miedo hacia nosotros que
nosotros hacia el que a lo mejor tiene
los mismos prejuicios que nosotros hacia
él pero que los va a perder yo os
aseguro que vuelves a casa con una
sonrisa con una calidez en el alma que
te hace mejor persona luego al día
siguiente cuando sales y alguno te pega
un bocinazo sonríes
y te das cuenta de que casi todo casi
todo en esta vida relativo - la salud y
la gente que queremos y el privilegio de
viajar el privilegio de poder salir hoy
en día que tenemos la suerte no como
nuestros abuelos o incluso hace 40 años
no era tan fácil viajar cuando me fui de
mochilero en el año 90 no era tan fácil
viajar pero hoy en día si yo reto a
vosotros y a vosotros a que la próxima
vez que viajes apagues del móvil y os
quitáis el reloj
a ver si sois capaces y que disfrutéis
cada momento cada sonrisa cada abrazo y
cada pueblo nos vemos por esos mundos
[Aplausos]